[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo el expresidente
estadounidense Donald Trump podrá volver
a usar Facebook e Instagram en las
próximas semanas meta la empresa dueña
de estas dos plataformas tomó la
decisión de restaurar sus cuentas
argumentando el derecho de los
ciudadanos a escuchar lo que dicen sus
políticos la decisión ha provocado una
ola de reacciones en contra y a favor
justo cuando el ex mandatario se prepara
para la contienda electoral de 2024 en
la que busca volver a la casa blanca
empezamos
después de dos años de suspensión la
empresa meta anunció que restaurará las
cuentas de Facebook e Instagram del
expresidente Donald Trump en las
próximas semanas de esta manera la
empresa de redes sociales se une a la
decisión de Twitter de traer de vuelta
al ex mandatario quien había perdido el
acceso a sus cuentas por incitar a la
violencia contra el Capitolio el 6 de
enero de 2021
una medida que generó polarización ya
que nunca antes habían bloqueado a un
jefe de estado en funciones recordemos
que varias de sus publicaciones habían
sido restringidas por difundir
información falsa sobre todo con temas
relacionados con el Coby 19 y las
vacunas metas sin embargo aclaró que
como cualquier usuario Trump está sujeto
a sus normas comunitarias y en caso de
que publique más contenido que infrinja
las normas estas publicaciones se
eliminarán y el expresidente podrá ser
suspendido nuevamente entre un mes a dos
años según la gravedad de la infracción
así justificó a la empresa la
restauración de Trump
las redes sociales se basan en la
creencia de que el debate abierto y el
libre flujo de ideas son valores
importantes especialmente en un momento
en que están amenazados en muchos
lugares del mundo como regla general no
queremos entorpecer El Debate abierto
público y democrático en las plataformas
de meta especialmente en el contexto de
elecciones en sociedades democráticas
como Estados Unidos el público debe
poder escuchar lo que dicen sus
políticos lo bueno lo malo y lo feo para
que puedan tomar decisiones informadas
en las urnas
a través de una publicación en su red
social
Trump celebró esta medida dijo que tal
cosa nunca debería volver a sucederle a
un presidente en ejercicio sin embargo
no está claro si volverá a publicar
contenido en Facebook o Instagram ni
cuando lo haría ya que desde que
recuperó su acceso a Twitter no ha
vuelto a enviar nuevos tuits sin embargo
según reportó la revista Rolling Stone
Trump estaría buscando deshacerse de un
acuerdo de exclusividad firmado con su
propia plataforma que lo obliga a que
sus comunicaciones primero se publiquen
allí de acuerdo con el informe una vez
deshecho el contrato Trump estaría listo
para volver a las grandes redes sociales
y es que contar con las plataformas de
meta podría ser clave ahora que aspira a
un nuevo periodo en la casa blanca para
la decisión de meta ha desatado toda una
serie de reacciones tanto a favor como
en contra políticos y organizaciones
defensoras de Derechos Humanos se han
sumado a esta discusión aquí algunos
ejemplos Angelo caruson presidente de la
organización media matters dedicada a
combatir las fake news dijo que meta
conoce el impacto de traer de vuelta a
Trump la empresa sabe que convertirá a
Facebook e Instagram en un pozo oscuro
de odio violencia y extremismo pero no
le importa Facebook es una plataforma
moribunda y meta hará cualquier cosa
para aferrarse a la relevancia y los
ingresos Incluso si eso significa poner
en peligro a sus usuarios y nuestra
democracia dice el comunicado el
representante a la cámara de Estados
Unidos Adam shift recordó que Trump
incitó una insurrección y trató de
detener la transferencia pacífica del
poder no ha mostrado remordimiento ni
contrición devolverle el acceso a una
plataforma de redes sociales para
difundir sus mentiras y demagogia es
peligroso Facebook se hundió dándole una
plataforma para hacer más daño agregó
Mientras tanto la representante
demócrata Janis jacobsky decía que esta
es una decisión peligrosa restablecer
las cuentas de Facebook e Instagram del
expresidente Trump solo Aviva la llama
del odio y la división que condujeron a
una insurrección meta ha tenido barreras
de seguridad que se han ignorado
repetidamente para cuentas de alto
perfil de otro lado están lo que se
demostraron a favor de que el
expresidente Donald Trump recuperará sus
cuentas de Instagram y Facebook veamos
algunos ejemplos la unión estadounidense
por las libertades civiles que fue
crítica con varias decisiones de la
Administración Trump dijo que es lo
correcto nos guste o no Trump es una de
las principales figuras políticas del
país y el público Tiene un gran interés
en escuchar su discurso el abogado danés
Jacob me echan gama defensor de la
libertad de expresión aseguró que meta
tomó la decisión correcta dice me gusta
especialmente el énfasis en el derecho
de los usuarios a acceder a la
información en palabras de Frederick
Douglas suprimir la libertad de
expresión es un doble mal viola los
derechos del oyente así como los del
hablante los comentarios A favor o en
contra no borran el hecho de que a su
eventual regreso a las grandes redes
sociales Trump podrá usarlas como un
vehículo clave para divulgación política
y la recaudación de fondos según
expertos quienes resaltan que su campaña
de 2016 fue pionera en lo que respecta
aprovechar el poder de las herramientas
de publicidad digital en Facebook y sus
campañas de 2016 y 2020 gastaron
millones en anuncios que fueron clave
para sus pequeños esfuerzos de
recaudación de fondos Y es que Trump
cuenta con más de 87 millones de
seguidores en Twitter 34 millones en
Facebook y 23 millones en instagram En
comparación con los casi 5 millones que
tiene en su propia red social true pero
estará Trump dispuesto a cumplir con las
reglas de estas plataformas ya lo
veremos hasta aquí revista digital
recuerde que si quieres repetir esta u
otra emisión de nuestro programa lo
puede hacer A través de nuestra página
web triple W punto France
[Música]